Hãy bà chung đỏ trong 2 ngày 6 xong bộ mọi thằng sau, tài xin vài nội bài và xin vài cắt mi,
phát hiện mà và thể bài nyi là típ y bay không me lãi, phương tiện bài khác,
anh hưởng chức tiếp đến hoạt động, khai thóc bay trong đó chỉ dừng tài xin vài nội bài,
sôi truyền bay bàn hưởng ngày 6 xong xong hoạt động của bây là 2 mi tạm trên bay,
em vui thằng sau, giòn hoạt động thả dều trong khu bực kết cạnh,
tổng số bởi truyền bay trên biệt khởi hành phải dinh chờ.
Con tài xin bay các bi hải phòng có bà truyền bay biển hưởng giòn hoạt động thả dều.
Theo đến giá của cuộc hàng không, hóa đồng của UAV và Zio Niu Chen,
vẫn có thể là 2, sự việc dẫn đến một số truyền bay biển hưởng đến khai thóc
và tìm và nguy cơ mất ăn toàn hoạt động bay đặc biệt tại thời điểm, hóa đồng bay mùa cao điểm.
Zi vui hay đối với học sinh có thể ra tăng hoạt động thả dều và cáp bất thể bay khác.
Giòn bay cuộc hàng không đến nghĩ một xây dân xem xét của ý công biển tới ui bàn dân các tình thành phố có sinh bay,
tuyên chuyển mì định của chính phủ về quan lý tà bay không người lấy và tệ bay khác.
Vì cơ mất ăn toàn hoạt động bay zor và tệ bay trong khu bực cầm bay hành trế bay của cả hàng không.
Sơn bay, ngoài ra cuộc hàng không cũng để xuất mục công an, mộ của phòng chỉ đau cứ đơn vị trực năng tại liều phương.
Sao đình gió đồng của tiếp nhận, sự lý thông tin khi phát hiện thiết biệt bay không người lấy, phương tệ bay khác và tệ bay hoạt động trả phép.
Nhằm bào đầm sự lý nhàng trong tìm thời và hiệu qua.